parfois j'ai envie d'être toute seule là
où je peux être autre chose qu'une
épouse ou une mère de
famille je suis pas défini par la
tragédie ça te manque jamais clar la
maison j'adore la vie qu'on a
ici la gouvernante ça rend tout plus
facile fait partie de la famille oui
c'est ce que tu dis sans arrêt tu es sa
patronne pas son
[Musique]
ami Hong Kong devait être un nouveau
départ pour moi un nouveau départ
vraiment à 24
ans je crois que mon couple est fichu
David est rentré non madame qu'estce que
je encore
ici tu t'es jamais imaginé vivre une vie
complètement
[Musique]
différente on se retrouve à les
surveiller à chaque seconde même quand
on a les yeux fermés je ne sais pas
comment ça a pu se
produire personne ne devrait avoir à
vivre ce que tu as
vécu
on devraitartir à la maison avec les
enfants sans aller d'ici on est enain de
noyer tu vois
rien pi seront plus sur le sol de Hong
Kong nousandon
[Musique]
notre Alam na Lahat
angyertin MGA sreto kahit
pin je pense à ce que j'ai
fait les gens comme moi parviennent-ils
à tourner la
page ce n'est pas trahir qui que ce soit
que de souhaiter d'avoir une vie
meilleure on doit tous continuer à
[Musique]
vivre même
toi